john's excusé aujourd'hui se trouve sur
colas d'un jeu d'horreur extrêmement
bien notée du coup j'ai envie d'y jouer
il est à 50 6 ans âge où neuf étudiants
de l'institut polytechnique de l'oural
entreprirent une expédition difficile en
hiver pour atteindre le mot au total ils
ont été retrouvés tous morts avec leurs
organes éparpillés sur la route vers la
fin de l'histoire
oh ça joue je crois que c'est une
thématique mon gars tellement c'est beau
la qualité d'exception mais mon gars je
veux qu'il y ait des deux fois les mais
qu'est ce que c'est bon ça fait peur
hein on dirait pas mais après à prévoir
les mecs qui font ça comme ça qui part
dans la neige à la par petits groupes et
où ils ont déboulé en titan mais jamais
je ferai ça à la limite je pars à
plusieurs devant un pc dans la neige sur
deux questions ont dû appeler petite
musique sympa qu'on s'amuse à chantonnay
je me sens faible déjà là je crois qu'on
va avoir besoin d'une collation
la [ __ ] j'ai près par les députés
cette vidéo celle là en foyer ou à la
fin de ce qu'on voit rien on voit rien
dans une tempête de ouf simulateur de
tempête de neige à je crois que c'est
par là ah oui là ça ça c'est le bon
chemin c'est sur un truc aussi
terrorisant voilà venez vous à moi de
qui acquit une grotte
non j'aime pas les grottes annoncerons
ces très courts à la fin la seule chose
que je vis était un éclair une lumière
insupportable et brûlante
la douleur a déchiré mon corps j'ai
senti arraché mon âme j'ai accueilli la
fin avec bonheur de clémente est tombé
dans un trou était mort il fait tout un
discours politique mais c'est ça qui
s'est passé au voyage on dirait qu'on
est dans l'écran de chargement des sims
qui tue c'est dans la dans la boîte
blanche là en exclusivité voici la
vision d'un assassin pendant les
chargements mais vous voilez bordel je
comprends pas est ce qu'on procède du
plaisir actuellement sur ce je peux la
réponse et nous avons dû aux mondiaux
enfin [ __ ] après dix minutes mais que
non mais beaucoup trop long de cette
phase de recherche c'est scandaleux
appuyez sur eux que j'ai pu avec grand
plaisir et une boussole à ya chargement
ça veut dire qu'on va puer dans la
tempête
oh oui on sort de la tente ya plus la
tempête on a une light en plus c'est
parfait c'est quoi ces traces de pas par
terre mon gars c'est l'oeil de seront
les dons et danseurs des anneaux là on
est dans le mordor en hiver [ __ ] mais
pas compris ok c'est pas faut aller mais
je me sens pas trop cet endroit il ya un
truc là un livre je me suis mise en
route et que je ne vais pas l'incident
jeter dans la région je me suis donc
signalé à l'unité pour que la ferme soit
automatiquement attribué à donc oui
c'est le mec qui enquête sur les neuf
mecs qui sont morts sur la route ce
n'est que le 26 avril nous avons trouvé
la tente qui je pense appartiennent aux
étudiants les premières conclusions
révélé que les personnes interrogées la
tante avait découpé ses flancs et pour
une raison que j'ignore avait essayé de
s'en échapper dans la panique
maman à temps pourquoi les cas où
s'envolent s'il sait pas ça ça aussi
dans le donnera à brive et wap nickel
ainsi mais c'est quoi ce délire mec
c'est beau
o o des gens qui crient qu on va le
suivre monsieur mathieu va le suivre
ça doit être les neuf mec c'est le
fantôme de 9 mais attendez moi j'ai pas
votre endurance non attends moi c'est
quoi ce bruit de lula reste calme et ben
voila sens de l'histoire c'est un loup
ok on avait une sorte de forêt avec des
fantômes par tous ces bateaux comme
décor sans déconner j'aimerais pas du
tout me toise cet endroit est un truc là
regardez ça l' indice s'est ensuite des
notes mystérieuse d'humières au dessus
du cosmodrome de ce baume ni
d'événements mystérieux était scellé
dans le ciel pendant la nuit du 4 au 5
juillet des témoins affirment avoir vu
une sphère orange vif traversé plusieurs
fois le ciel au dessus de la ville ok
super c'est quoi ce bruit attend ça
s'abroge bateau ça l'île entière est un
bateau c'est ça le secret continue ma
route là où non aux [ __ ] ainsi un bon
gars qui me font peur c'est qu'on allait
vous sur vous sur voo suite vous allez
où vous allez vous vous allez où je vous
suis moi c'est beau mais un peu un peu
flippant et voilà j'ai perdu leur trace
comme à chaque fois aux écritures à
cette racine de hand 73 et galeux hockey
auger trouver note au pied d'un arbre
extrêmement flippant qu'est ce qu'elle
dit nous avons découvert les premiers
corps près de sapins un feu de camp
improvisé indiqué qu'ils avaient essayé
de se réchauffer en ont les corps
étaient en sous vêtements uniquement en
os x 12
j'ai découvert les locaux or chacun
séparés de quelques centaines de mètres
dans la même zone
leur position a indiqué que les victimes
avaient essayé de regagner la tente
aussi vite que possible ça peut vouloir
dire que la menace était parti que le
groupe avait décidé de retourner à la
tente ou à l inverse qui avait un truc
dans la forêt qui apparut et du coup
tout le monde a voulu retourner à la
tente
arrêtez ça fait peur ah non là c'est pas
la face d'où le bond sera de suivre
j'espère paula la tempête se lève non
non j'ai eu ma dose de trempettes s'il
vous plaît au wat afin moi ta phut aux
attentes non mais ça va pas du tout là
il ya des ya des ombres mon gars je vais
crever mon gars je vais crever ya un
monde qui me suit et sérieux le cours à
un succès déverrouiller mais je veux pas
de ce succès en plus sur l'année il ya
des témoins
je crois qu'il m'a vu lustucru je suis
président c'est pas drôle panzani
pourquoi pas d'arêtes à temps mais c'est
quoi ce délire l'adhésion qui me suivent
moi je veux pas de zone qui le suivent
moi je veux que la lumière dans ma vie
que ce soit un long fleuve tranquille
on est bien plus moment les enfants n'y
a aucune eau on est extrêmement bien par
contre j'aimerais vraiment que les héros
dans les jeux d'horreur ce dock il est
dix fois plus de ce prix de ce serait
génial cxc ces nouveaux groupes de 6 to
see ok personne n'a envie d'être dans
cet endroit à ce moment avec ce temps
même compte
l'abonnement world of warcraft personnes
veulent on est bien là lâche ans qu'on
est bien on a trouvé la piste verte la
piste vers ben c'est pas du tout en
descente ok nous revoilà aux quatre
cailloux alors est ce qu est ce qui va
leur revenir là ou pas eh bien non voilà
eh ben c'est parti pour 70 minutes de
marche tout le monde est très impatient
de me coucher à 3 heures du matin que
verrons-nous jusqu'où irons-nous
j'entends le reste du groupe respect
paisiblement ils nagent dehors d'accord
donc c'est en gros une personne du
groupe qui a écrit ça avant le départ
oui ça y est [ __ ] nouvelle phase
génial qui se fait là ça a tendu un
piège avec des pieux comme ça quoi si on
part sur un délire comme ça moi je vais
piloter un hoquet sa part en délire
obscur je suis dans le mal absolu je
vais remettre la chanson pour me booster
sa mangouste part ça ne repousse pas au
plus tard d'un chef op choses
incroyables c'est vers ce qu'il s'agit
d'une ville fermée dans l'oblast de
tomsk en russie située à 15 km au nord
ouest de tom elle est entre les mains de
rosatom l'agencé fédérale de l'énergie
atomique
elle comprend plusieurs réacteurs
nucléaires et les usines chimiques pour
la séparation l'enrichissement et le
retraitement d'uranium et de plutonium
hockey devrait avoir des mecs qui sont
pris des radiations et qu'ils ont
totalement défendre mais c'est ça qui
est ça m'a retourné ce petit éclat elle
est là à certains moments je doute que
nous soyons prêts pour une telle
expédition dépenses et perturbante me
hante
nous avons peut-être pas l'évaluer nos
capacités c'est un peu trop tard du coup
cocotte au j'appelle ça depuis tellement
longtemps
tout cela me fait extrêmement peur je
pense que c'est le moment pour aller
chez coiffe un bébé je suis en total t
si tu regardes sous mes bras tu pourras
y trouver de na sueur ola olé trappe
quoi quoi quoi quoi c'est par là j'ai
pas peur moi bref à voir les traces
rouges en vrai attend à mais pas du tout
ca
c'est par la tension le pont et je parle
pas celui que tu fais rentrer un jour
férié le week end au home est en colonie
tous ensemble dans la neige en s'amusant
oui stop le bristol le groupe sam
terrorisme touristes of no pourquoi
c'est ouvert je sais pas c'est quoi ça
n'avait aucune idée de ce qu'il se
passait j'ai fini j'ai fini par
atteindre un petit prêt j'ai trouvé un
journal relié comme si quelqu'un avait
fait exprès de laisser là le journal
appartenant aux membres de l'expédition
ils ont écrit leurs pensées leurs
observations ok c'est la fin je me casse
la croûte je me cache
je suis caché je vous vois c'est faux il
se passe quoi là on se calme j'ai peur
moi oh elle j'en ai marre non mais je
vais l'aider qui est là quel âge pour la
lanterne qui est là haut au sa mère le
tec sa mère le steak vous êtes mort ok
oui mais j'en suis fière de cette vidéo
sur colette butin s'éveiller intense je
l'aï eu en fait ses crescendos a fait ça
je me suis défoncé doigt contre le
plafond en tout cas graphiquement c'est
une bombe
et l'histoire elle est hyper intéressant
de quoi enquêter sur des neuf mecs qui
sont morts dans cette forêt on sait pas
pourquoi c'est assez bien fait pour le
manger aucune idée de ce qui s'est passé
voilà mais ça va regarder à se retrouver
dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien sûr tout le monde
pis